hey guys it's just Dayton today we were
doing one of the most massive tech hauls
that I've ever done this unboxing is
absurd I got so many things over the
holidays and a bunch of the stuff I got
last year and I hadn't got a chance to
check out or open or review so I thought
let's do it all in one big massive crazy
video there's also two boxes on the
ground so we've got a lot of stuff to
cover today I'm gonna try to go sort of
quickly but also I just need to say a
huge thank you to guys for supporting my
channel for supporting me over the past
four freaking ever so while I'm doing
this unboxing of a lot of cool stuff I
also wanted to give you guys something
and I make this super simple I'll be
sending it to you directly from Amazon
I'll probably put in like an echo show
or like an echo dot or a couple of
things from the Amazon line this is not
sponsored at all I just felt like I'm
opening a bunch of stuff and a lot of
you guys are watching this and saying I
want something too we're just totally
normal totally fair so I see you I hear
you
all you have to do is like comment
subscribe on this video and then tweet
me some photo proof that you guys did it
my twitter handle is I just II and of
course you can follow me on Twitter as
well and you might as well follow me on
Instagram because maybe I'll post the
winner on Instagram Wow let's really
make this a super silly crazy scavenger
hunt so with that being said my friends
welcome to my 1st 2019 crazy wild tech
haul there's so many random things in
here I gave also I got something here
from Lilly which I'm excited about I got
the Opel Lamborghini foam that I got a
long time ago and never really got a
chance to check out I got a Red Dead
Redemption little surprise here what if
we put these items off to the side are
you like how are you why are you rolling
me back oh this is not what I thought
was gonna be in this box
read and relax what is this there's some
lotion this is actually one of my
favourite brands of lotion too so that's
something did I just turn into a beauty
vlogger and I didn't know it mmm the
stuff is incredible in its lavender oh I
feel so relaxed already slippers I'm
gonna go put these in the bath right now
all new Kindle paperwhite Oh a reviewers
guide they sent me this a long time ago
so I feel like this has probably been
out for like 7 months are
with Bluetooth built-in listen to your
favorite wait a minute I can listen to
audible on my Kindle isn't even an
audible sponsorship my Kindle came with
bath supplies leave this what's in here
the city is gonna take me five hours to
film in 20 hours edit it smells really
good
is this from Russia this is from lush oh
my goodness if this is a bath bomb I'm
gonna be so I may have been held it not
just one we've got to this is a very
strong smell I think I'm gonna take a
bath later
I love lush may not seem like it but I
do freakin Rob okay well it looks like I
may have been out in the barn with my
robe but it's a very sweet gesture
God I'm spending five hours on this
Kindle oh I thought that was a sticker
but that was just the scream aside you
guys know I'm a huge Xbox fan I really
don't play battlegrounds that often I
did play when it first came out but I am
a huge huge fan of all the custom
controllers so thank you Xbox for this
this actually came out a while ago and
what I do love about this controllers
too is they will work with the news 10
and I have a Microsoft Surface laptop
that I use a lot when I travel so I will
use a controller and I came with a
controller on my PC I know it's
counterintuitive but I don't really want
to hear your judgement cuz I'm not here
for that even though this is the
internet and you're free to judge I just
don't care I used to care a lot more in
the moment they stop carrying things
when you start living so guess what I'm
gonna use a controller with my PC
although I do say that but then what I
was at CES I was checking out the Razer
Titan that they have it's basically a
keyboard mouse setup for your xbox pc
gaming with the controller mouse and
keyboard gaming on a console I don't
know I just wish that I had more time to
play video games I used to play so much
more but the good news is
at the time that I used to spend playing
video games I go outside I work out now
and I try not to watch Netflix so my
quality of life since I've played less
video games has actually significantly
improved that doesn't mean that I don't
love sitting and just playing a game and
completely losing myself but that's when
you need to try to have some things sort
of counterbalance is that like okay if
you just play games for five hours go
for a hike go for a walk go for a run
jog I don't know do something so that
was something that I had to learn last
year so hopefully I can instill some of
that go outside mentality suits you as
well echo show this is one of the newer
ones which I'm excited about because I
really do love the echo
I just I'm such a sucker for all smart
home devices and yeah if you're gonna
start jumping into crazy privacy issues
look the moment that you have a phone in
your hand you post anything on the
internet like you're basically giving
away your life so just just know about
it I judge you this the wrong way my
sister like lift it up like this oh I
guess so look at you look at you and
your little hat you've got a little hat
on
I used to wear that one Tiffany's tea
necklace all the time and a lot of you
guys were like is that an amazon smile
necklace mm no but I love animals oh wow
the screen is a lot bigger than the
previous version this is like one of my
favorite kitchen devices probably gonna
set this up and drop in on my friend ed
oh that is nomina sound so I guess while
that's happening we're gonna open up
this box from Lily I've got a little
note steak Hosey oh my gosh skittles yes
please
ooh what do we got here
oh it's loading
it's loading something's happening oh
this is super cute Lily these are
awesome I oh my gosh these are great I
love them I want a super cute jacket too
yes I could have used this drawing it
was past couple of weeks cuz it was
raining so bad this is so cute
thanks girl I was it gonna take a while
yes surface headphones super hyped about
that okay thank you huge clock it was a
stock oh it's a timer this is nice I can
put this in my gym little little what do
they call it sweat bands is that what is
that what they're called do people wear
those I sure think they do but they this
is the thing I'm gonna I'll put them in
the gym can i push the button okay hmm
water-resistant let's see what's you
guys got in here oh this [__] fuse
like it supposed to be good charger in
there no there's a whole other level
here's the power station XL a little
mini guy I like this because it's more
the plastic feel some of the previous
ones they had is like a it's like a soft
kind of like material this is so much
packaging
wow what a cable hello yes please that's
still updating next up we've got some
surface headphones these are great I'm
so excited to add this to like my
surface setup I'm loving the new surface
studio it's such a great machine and
these are gonna look so great with it
Jenna has been using hers for a while
and I was like hey I gotta go open them
this case that's a big case this new
tech yeah they are I like the little
foam cups here those are super soft
hello
these are cool I'm going to charge them
up
goodbye should just said goodbye I've
got a favorite one five millimeter
headphone jack just in case you decide
[__] them in which is good because I'd
been needing some good wired headphones
for what I'm shooting videos are you
you're still not set up yet so this is
the Oppo Lamborghini collaboration Wow I
just I'm such a sucker for carbon fiber
whenever I wasn't ordering my car I was
like I need the carbon fiber trend
static Wow super fancy I just I've
already smudged it up oh oh oh we've got
accessory gosh I love braided USB cables
so much and this is a USBC one look at
this industrial not a plug that I can
use here but I guess when I travel this
little this will be lovely this is huge
it doesn't absolutely just absolutely
massive silver what are you oh look at
that
those are super super fancy and I like
that they don't have the rubberized
stuff on them the rubber stuff just it
kind of ends up actually hurting my ears
oh yeah these are these are nice I don't
think they're gonna quite stay in my ear
though I just got jammed in there a
little more maybe okay that hurt oh gosh
there's this is the gift that keeps
giving oh nice carbon-fiber lamborghini
case I love the accessories like this
just looks super fancy like now I want
to go out and drive a Lamborghini I had
zero interest in driving one previous to
opening this home isn't that kind of
like the reverse like [__] and I want to
buy this phone because I'm super into
Lamborghinis no I just got a cool phone
those Lamborghini printed and he'll like
what a coat drive one of their cars I
don't know can we skip this because like
I don't I really don't want to I don't
want to see almost done well jeez it's
only five hours later next up this is
one that made this a long time ago this
is kind of cool it's called power pick
wireless charger it's a wireless charger
but it's also a picture frame she's
certified fast charger delivers up to 10
watts of wireless power why are the
charges repel
this is video saying your specialty in
editing is like nothing like it am i
doing this completely oh wait okay it
said okay lift here to open but that's
counterintuitive because it says list
here to open but it's also like upside
down wow look at this this is cool what
picture am I going to put here this is
such a cute idea what is this I'll
probably put a picture of my dog in here
drop in on Edie did you mean in Palumbo
yes hello are you doing the dishes are
you taking a shower are you peeing are
you okay are you you did let me see my
read that I feel like a super creep
right now it looks like he's out so
maybe I'll send him a picture of me at
his house that was super fun I had a
really great time in Ed's house while Ed
wasn't there let's move on to this when
I originally read the packaging I
thought it was like a digital photo
frame but it's like an actual real
picture frame but you can charge your
phone this is pretty exciting this game
in a bigger set of Red Dead Redemption
stuff but I had opened the other things
before the holidays and I found this one
that I hadn't opened yet I love candles
I love red dead I wished I would have
played more over the holidays my
family's internet was so bad that every
time I would go to play my xbox and I
would do an update that it would take so
long did by the time I got my update it
was time to come back to Los Angeles
oh my gosh I am so in love with it this
is an intercom this whole thing is a
candle oh my god it smells so good I'm a
beauty vlogger this whole thing
a candle blood-orange incense amber rock
rose smoked cedar sandalwood violet leaf
and juniper tar scented black wax candle
we've got a couple of other things here
these I'm really excited about
so also over the holidays I finally got
one of the razor 2 phones and it is a
really amazing phone here's a few of the
accessories that I didn't get a chance
to open yet this is the wireless charger
looks fairly simple oh yeah that looks
good my cord wasn't long enough to do it
was like pulling on the cable so that
looks cool also they send over their
hammerhead USBC headphones these are
awesome nice little carrying case oh
yeah look at that just like their
attention to detail is something that I
love so much like the headphones even
have little lights on them as well whoa
okay this is Wi-Fi has no internet
access I know because my infant sucks
like Time Warner spectrum I don't
understand how you're such trash love
this little carrying case so much that's
a little clipping everything super
overwhelmed Cydia is almost over next up
oh this is something that I was gonna do
an entirely dedicated video to and then
I ran out of time and everyone else
released their videos so I just never
did it this is the Google pics of slate
tada okay so first up let's keep those
accessories directions
nothing's charging brick of course USBC
hey whoa there was more things in their
head phone jack dongle how many hosts
should we see today my video cut because
sony a7s 2 only goes to 29 minutes which
is one of the things I really wanted one
of the newer cameras is so just please
not have a recording length for the sake
of my sanity and a lot of other people
sanity and every time I start filming
there's I mean are we looking for some
criminals are we looking for criminals
there's a helicopter if you can't hear
it should I say hi are you do you want
to say hi like what's happening out
there
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm gonna go inside now because that's
pretty freakin close to
it looks like there may be some criminal
activity they were flying right above my
house the police were here so what you
guys missed in the unboxing because
everything basically shut off I unbox
the pixel pen the pixels like keyboard
and the pixel slate itself and there's
also one last thing this is actually our
last bit of unboxing I'm exhausted this
was a lot of stuff my recycling bin is
going to be super full rich Wireless
Keyboard take a look at wow this is
heavy this is super heavy ok no it's not
it was picking up the box so this is
another little keyboard option for your
pixel slate like right into it like that
so I think that I might like the other
one a little more because it's lighter
and this one is also just like a
wireless keyboard so it'll probably just
connect with Bluetooth it seems like and
I don't really like this little I don't
like that I don't like this at all
actually it does match very nice though
so that's a good thing but I think I
might prefer this other folio case
instead another thing that you missed is
I was struggling to figure out how to
get this to stand up because I didn't
read the directions
obviously I'm kind of used to the
surface or like the iPad like it's super
simple you just kind of like to go like
that or on the surface it has it built
in but you just had this case down and
then it magnetizes itself to the back at
first I was like it's an interesting
choice but now that I've been kind of
messing with it a little bit they of
course you guys would have seen it but
my camera cut and I'm kind of into it
magnifying glass look at this capture
region I'll capture that great great
screenshot well guys that was just a
very massive tech haul probably one of
the biggest I've ever done
a lot of this stuff like I said had just
built up over time and I just wanted to
share it with you guys and do a fun
unboxing and like I said at the
beginning if you guys wanted to enter to
win my Justina sending me something from
Amazon I don't know what it is surprise
gift box make sure you subscribe to my
channel like this video comment below
and take a screenshot of all of those
things and tweet it to me and I just
need
what's my heart rate it's probably
super-high kitten all aimed up control
this tech
[Music]